welcome to this video playing hon for 13
yup have this is funnier there I have a
hundred one hundred percent score
against him five out of five and this is
the game where I'm getting an all-time
high with the wind so that's a bit of a
tease right okay let's just develop him
I remember I had this against him I had
this against him earlier let's see I'm
just I'm just developing him playing
playing simple stuff knight c6
okay let's clarify the situation here oh
I did not think about this one really
okay this what a bunch is easy for is
this very very crude right efore see for
now that's not a good idea let me just
develop him
what am i doing now I d5 not sure about
that not sure those traits to help me
but I want to play now don't don't want
to get into huge time disadvantage in
this game sorry likely that you will
take i mean bishop be 797 looks wrong I
can take Quincy 2h7 and c5 is hanging so
i can check c5 and you will take a bit
too so I'm going to do that Jake's be 20
30 g5g I be 60 but i have work a five
push up there okay push ups III rook a
three maybe he can kind of pursue my
rook all the time that's may be possible
there should be two look a six though
for Bishop reform okay 64 Bishop b4
Bishop c4 I will look Bishop c4 here
brah Bishop c4 Bishop a8 push up chicks
f1 you should three and back that's not
good ok any other move here i have f to
take it's just as useless i have to take
ok yeah Bishop f1 looks and forced why
did I not see that one I don't know but
I'm can be glad that it's just about
working
it's just about working um oh really
before we for Bishop g5 don't know we
should be three as some possibility
maybe just this one first I'm not sure I
can move the bishop now
don't have a phone now this is the big
issue to have 54 now we should be for
was really bad why what did i do that no
idea
hmm can i maybe go should be aid
counter-attacking this
I don't whatever yet game not really a
checking this shampoo there I wonder if
he has a discovered move with the rook
there that it looks scary really looks
scary
I never had time to make her make some
look for my king there
check no I presenting with check I
thought we can't believe it i'm gifting
this game away ah no I don't believe it
ah can I draw somehow at least this I
came at least I don't really see any
didn't see a really great move for him
rook c8 is a threat at least now
maybe f4 is a possibility trying to cut
off his rook adduser' maybe an idea prac
practical idea
a four-week c4 hmm I'm I mean at least
that's not easy to win I mean for him I
don't so don't think it's easy to win
first glance Misha page 4 check yes yeah
you saw that one great okay rook edge
for Bishop f6 check can I have somehow
create create and check out of this so
it's almost made so check almost check
check yeah I'm gambling now what what
their come check
okay can you form eyes got the chick
down check and he will just check check
check Oh b7 this almost made genuine
stuff check oh yeah yeah yeah I'm just
wants a draw okay check what I want my
pawn slip can I do something with my
pawns check check check black yes yes
time I mean I was just trying to avoid
all drawers to get a winning at all
costs I mean I have no idea what the
times the Jewish to us actually we both
didn't have anything okay I back Wow get
is to see these games weight is all
about the high school they're always
always tricky how did I get myself into
this not detect get into trouble out of
this here Wow Bishop here let's have a
look there okay mother can't be should
be for ya sometimes I can just go hello
we should pee or something and I'm
really just a pawn up for for absolutely
nothing and this Wow Bishop before was
really bad I mean that that was a stupid
move really it damn it is just not
helping me at all I mean Bishop d3 yes
okay but I should go here
so that this is this is a useless and
it's not it's not really clear what he's
doing then maybe back I just need like
one move like g4 or something to make
sure i'm not back rank meter then I'm
keeping my phone I mean it's not like
it's an automatic win with the porn but
it is some it is something that I can of
course just just try 10 now now i'm
just-just in trouble very difficult to
yeah okay what this wins already okay
mm-hmm and beckon hmm yeah that is bad a
g4s extremely fine right hey I simply
forgot that is on Jenna fryer in half or
to move jam ok it's am it's of course um
I should do this the a porn is still
quite dangerous so it's it's a question
if i can draw this i mean i prob'ly can
because my king is it's relatively quick
in helping and his king is a bit back
yeah i guess it's a draw but ultimately
this means if we check this here you see
25 17 april 29 yeah i know we just
uploaded a bit later but this is the
all-time five minute hi okay well thanks
for watching guys